just doesn't seem fair that I could save
a city and not say it my relationship I
can't do this yeah I can't believe hi
the silent just because damian darhk--
is in jail I'm just going ahead with
Genesis but not with you
till death do us listen II convinced me
that we could save the city and not
surrender to the darkness but I don't
think we can
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new arrow
trailer and confirmed season 5 so let's
break it down first things first let's
talk about this Cupid trailer and that's
what the title broken-hearts is all
about Cupid his back supposedly waging a
war on all the lovers of the city so
Oliver and Felicity used themselves as
bait even though they're technically on
a break she kind of gave him the ring
back so you could say they're broken up
maybe they're not broken up they haven't
really explained that yet
relationship status it's complicated
when you see Merlyn visiting damian
darhk-- in prison you see laurel getting
ready to prosecute him
you see Willa riding on the backs of
limos getting driven into buildings she
is probably having more fun than anyone
on this cast right now they're giving
her all the fun stunts we're gonna put
you on the back of this limo and run you
right through that building now on to
season 5 stuff hell yeah so what the
heck is going on the CW renewed pretty
much every single show that it has and
as crazy as that sounds it was a pretty
safe bet that arrow and flash were
coming back and even though legends of
tomorrow's ratings aren't quite as good
as arrows it's still crushing relative
to the other programming that the CW has
so amongst all the CW shows all of the
comic book stuff all the arrow flash
legends of tomorrow stuff is killing it
so yeah it's definitely coming back
there's still a couple really big plot
points that have to be resolved this
season one there's the person that winds
up in the grave - there's damien darhk's
fate 3 there's Merlin's fate and then
four there's whatever giant plan that
hive is planning for Star City so even
though there are eight episodes left
which is a lot there's really only like
four big things that they're gonna be
resolving they'll be other stuff going
on but really those four big things and
really the biggest thing is the grape
like who's gonna die and what's gonna
happen to team arrow after that person
dies because there's still a couple
strong candidates all the actors have
been really tight-lipped they haven't
been posting on social media as much I'm
sure they've got a couple strongly
worded emails and phone calls just to
not give away spoilers of any kind but
the good thing is is that in celebrating
the season 5 renewal a couple things
were said by some of the actors
primarily John Barrowman probably the
most active person on the cast on social
media he was just congratulating
everyone and saying sorry I can't be
there for heroes and villains fan fest
because there was a big convention that
a lot of the actors went to recently and
he said I can't wait to get so much more
evil next season me
that he will totally be around next
season he's not gonna be dying anytime
soon his name is Merlin the magician
he's one of the best actors that they
have so of course they're gonna try and
keep him around I'd like to get to the
point in arrow season 5 where Oliver
isn't quite so inconsistent internally
where he's like okay I know exactly what
I'm gonna do with this villain this guy
needs to die everyone else can live will
put them in prison I'd really like him
to be more sure of the decisions he's
making even if they're the wrong
decisions Merc Guggenheim has said
something in the past along the lines of
Oliver's mistakes being this big asset
for the show from a writing standpoint
because if he made perfect decisions all
the time there'd be no drama on the show
and he wouldn't need all of team arrows
held I think one of the biggest
complaints I've heard about this season
is that he feels like such a background
player and they have been developing the
rest of team arrow really well I think
that's just a natural thing as arrow
gets on it seasons like if we get to
arrow season 7 of course there's gonna
be more Diggle focused episodes of
course there's gonna be more Thea
focused episodes so while I'm not
expecting it to happen overnight I love
to see season five Oliver hem and haw
less about the tough decisions he needs
to make I'd like to see him actually
enacting the plans that he makes even if
they're terrible decisions I think it's
more fun to see the action of the plan
than to see like an entire episode where
he's wondering what the plan should be
but from a comic book standpoint there
are a couple Givens for season five one
they just built that new arrow cape so
I'm not expecting them to do longbow
hunters and go to Seattle or anything
like that and you also have to remember
that the new layer is underneath his
campaign office so if he doesn't rejoin
the race for mayor ship of Star City
what are they gonna do with that office
next season is it gonna be like a flower
shop even if Oliver becomes mayor his
office is gonna move to City Hall so
mayor Queen or no mayor Queen they're
gonna have to do something different
with the office in season five so I
wouldn't go too crazy trying to theorize
season five because it's so early in
season four right now but I definitely
think that Oliver is gonna resolve the
damian darhk-- plot Merlyn will escape
to cause mischief in season five somehow
and most of team arrow will remain
largely intact now part of me is
wondering he like in the back of my head
if they're killing someone off the show
so that they could bring someone else in
or if they're doing the supernatural
thing if you've ever watched
Supernatural where they just winnow the
cast down there's just fewer cast
members season two season
we'll see either team arrow is going to
shrink by one or it's gonna remain the
same size and someone else will come in
in season five but as for who that would
be I don't know that it would be vixen
necessarily because I think she would go
to legends of tomorrow let me know in
the comments if we do lose one of the
costumes from team arrow who would you
want them to bring in so what's gonna
happen next is is we got some more info
on the flash Super Bowl crossover I'll
probably do a video for that there's a
new spider-man video that I'm planning
to do so be sure to subscribe to get
that stuff there's still one more week
to go before arrow and flash come back
but daredevil is dropping this Friday
and then the week after that Batman V
Superman is dropping so there's still
crazy stuff happening this week so why
you guys wait for more spider-man to
post you can click here for my flash
season 3 video and you can click here
for the Batman V Superman trailer I
posted this morning thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight high five for
season five